friend of the show mark roba is back
with a hot new take on the hot tub
you're sitting in a hot tub filled to
the brim with solid sand
[Music]
what mark is turning solid sand into a
liquid and it's making a splash online
with over 24 million views this is just
incredible I really want one of these in
my house no seriously I do we were
hotfooting it over to California to take
a dip into our first quantum leap I
wanted to capture the true like first
reaction of what it felt like when we
turned it on and so when I'm sitting
there at the beginning
that's legitimately the first time that
we turned it on and this sensation of
just sitting on something that's
completely solved and then suddenly it
just liquefies it's a crazy weird weird
feeling the whole bill took us about two
months I'd say half of that was just
doing the prototypes and getting all of
that like figured out the general
principles and then the other half was
actually building the hot tub no it sure
wasn't quicksand so how did mark upgrade
this hot sand pit mark has made what is
known as a fluidized bed this is where
air is pumped through the sand which
makes it behave like a liquid when the
air is switched off it returns to
behaving more like a solid it just stops
mark has 18 copper pipes that run side
by side at the bottom of the hot tub
into these he's drilled over two and a
half thousand holes which are regularly
spaced and all pointing down so the sand
doesn't get stuck in there those pipes
are welded to one big pipe that's
connected to three cylinders of nitrogen
gas then Mark fills a hot tub with over
one ton of dry sand
[Music]
but how does he make this an act like a
liquid when Mark opens the nitrogen
cylinders the gas goes between the sand
grains reducing the friction in between
them the gas provides an upward force on
each grain of sand which counteracts the
force of gravity so if those two forces
are in equilibrium the sand just hovers
the gas flow has to be just right to
allow the sand grains to move freely
over each other if the gas is coming out
too quickly it will give too much force
to the grains of sand and they will fly
out of the hot tub too little gas and
the sand won't really move at all
what's so weird is that when you pull
your hand up or you get out like it's
completely dry like that's the part
that's like what is happening like this
isn't quite right this looks like a lot
of fun until you have to get sand out of
places